In the last video, we
gave a basic outline
of the different scenarios
that might play out in 2013.
Or at least the different
budgetary proposals
on the table from
the administration,
from the Republicans,
and what will
happen if they don't
come into agreement,
which was the fiscal cliff.
Which is this fairly
unusual situation
where the both parties
to the negotiation
set up this thing that
will automatically
happen at the beginning of 2013.
That it would be painful
for both parties,
and the thinking
being that it'll
force them to come, maybe,
to some type of an agreement
sooner than later.
The fiscal cliff is what
neither the Republicans
or the administration want
because it raises taxes, which
the Republicans don't want,
and, it reduces spending,
which the president
doesn't want.
And the core argument, and we
touched it on the last video
and we'll go in more
depth in this one,
is just as we're
beginning to recover
from our last
recession, it might not
be useful for our economy to
try to suck out $1/2 trillion.
So let's think about the
different issues at play.
So right over here,
we have some charts.
Most of these are from the
Congressional Budget Office.
And there's a bunch of
assumptions that go into this.
And there many people
will debate the assumption
that they make.
But they at least directionally
show the right things.
So this right over
here, this first chart,
compares deficits or surpluses.
And really, ever
since the early 2000s,
we've been running deficits.
And as we got into
the late, I guess,
'10s, or 2008, 2010
timeframe, 2009 timeframe.
As we went into a
financial crisis.
When the economy
contracts, you get
hit in two ways when you
think about deficit spending.
On one end, you bring
in less revenues.
The economy is shrinking.
And on the other end,
you have to spend more.
You have to give
people more benefits.
More unemployment benefits.
Things like that.
So whenever you see the
economy shrink, you will see,
naturally, all other
things being equal,
you will see deficits increase.
And that's what you
saw right over here.
And on top of that,
the government
is trying to bail things out as
doing stimulus spending and all
that in order to minimize
the effect of the deficit.
And that's why you see
here in 2008, 2009,
we start running
significant deficits.
Now, what's
interesting is what's
going to happen going forward.
And going forward, there's two
of these scenarios right here.
There is the CBO's
baseline projection
and then there's the
alternative fiscal scenario.
And just to be
clear where we, we
are entering this phase
right over here in 2013.
And the baseline
projection is essentially
if the government
takes no more action.
And if the government
takes no more action,
then the fiscal cliff
will be triggered.
We will essentially have $500
billion less in 2013's deficit.
And so what you see here
is that the deficits
go down dramatically.
We have to borrow less
on an annual basis.
Now, the alternative
to fiscal scenario
is if we essentially continue--
if we extend our existing
spending, and if we continue to
extend the Bush era tax cuts,
we go along this path.
And so if you care a lot about
deficits, the fiscal cliff
scenario, which
is this top line.
This is actually the fiscal--
let me write that in a color
you can see-- that's actually
the fiscal cliff scenario.
It actually looks pretty good.
Hey, look, we have much, much
lower deficits in that scenario
than if we were to
continue the tax cuts,
and if we were to
continue the spending.
So there that looks
like, actually,
an argument for
the fiscal cliff.
Now let's look at this.
Now, this is-- we're going to
talk about the aggregate debt.
When we say deficit,
we're talking
about the shortfall
in a given year.
The debt is the aggregate
amount that the government owes.
So this is federal debt
held by the public,
historically and as
projected in CBO's baseline.
And CBO, when they
project, they can only
do so much in projecting how
good the economy might be,
or how bad it might be.
To a large degree,
they extrapolate
from where we are right now.
And right over here, you see
debt as a percentage of GDP.
So you could imagine
during World War II,
we had a lot of debt
as a percentage of GDP.
See over here after the
end of World War II,
we start crossing over
100% of GDP as our debt--
the aggregate amount
that the government owes.
And then it delevered.
And then you see this
rough trend, roughly
from the early '80s
until now, where
we've had increasing
aggregate debt.
There were some moments in the
late '90s, early 2000s, where
we took it down-- very,
very, very strong economy.
We started running surpluses.
We started to pay
down some of our debt.
But then we hit back on this
debt increasing trend line.
And once again,
if we continue in
the alternative fiscal scenario,
which is really continuing
to do what we do today,
which is extend the tax cuts
and continue to have roughly
the same level of spending,
you see that the debt only
continues to increase.
In the baseline
projection-- this
is actually the
fiscal cliff scenario.
This is where no new
legislation has passed.
Those triggers in which the
Bush era tax cuts expire,
and the spending cuts that are
triggered by the fiscal cliff
scenario hit, we
run lower deficits.
And we actually see that
debt, as a percentage of GDP,
actually starts to go down.
Which is, at least from a
balance sheet prospective,
seems like a good thing.
So these first two charts say,
hey maybe this fiscal cliff
thing isn't so bad.
It will actually
significantly lower
the deficit on an annual basis.
And as a percentage of GDP,
we will as a country, delever.
Now let's think
about the arguments
why well, maybe we don't want
to be that aggressive when
it comes to reducing
our deficit,
or reducing our debt
as a percentage of GDP.
This first chart
right over here is
the-- we'll read
it right over here.
It's the percent of our
population that is employed.
And you see right--
so it's a proxy
for employment or unemployment.
Or, in this case,
it's employment.
And you see we hit
a major recession
at the end of end of 2008.
You saw the percentage
of our population
that is employed go
down dramatically.
We kind of hit bottom
over here, and we're
having a shaky-- hopefully,
a shaky recovery right now.
It's not even clear
how good that will be.
But hopefully we're having
a shaky recovery of sorts.
And so just as we're
starting to recover,
it might not be helpful to
take, essentially, $500 billion
out of the economy in
order to pay down debt.
So the fiscal cliff
scenario might
make us go back into a
little bit of a lurch.
And most economists
are predicting about
on the order of 1% slower
growth if the fiscal cliff
scenario were to hit.
Actually, most
economists-- not 1%,
they're actually expecting
about a 2% hit to the economy
if the fiscal cliff
scenario would happen.
And rather from going
from 1.7% growth,
we might go to negative--
a slight recession,
slight receding of the economy.
So that's obviously not a good
scenario that we want to be in.
The other chart that I
have right over here,
these are yields on 10
year treasury notes.
This seems like a very
technical thing to talk about.
But this is essentially
the interest.
One way to think
about it is this
is the interest
that the government
is paying when it borrows
money for 10 years.
And one of the main arguments
for paying down debt
is that, if the government
keeps borrowing money,
it's going to crowd
out other borrowers.
It's going to make
demand for money high.
And maybe the supply will
be more and more scarce.
And interest rates will go up.
So a lot of borrowing could
make interest rates go up.
And then the other
idea is, well,
if there's a lot of just
borrowing and spending going
on.
And if we don't have a lot
of productive capacity,
it could also lead to inflation.
Or maybe when the
government has a huge debt,
they have an incentive to try
to have inflationary policies.
So that in real terms,
that debt seems to be less.
But when you look
at the debt markets,
and these are market
driven numbers.
The Federal Reserve does
not control 10 year yields.
The Federal Reserve
controls short term yields.
You see that we have
historically low interest
rates.
So the bond market-- and
there's some very smart people
who make their living
investing in the bond markets,
one of the biggest markets,
if not the biggest.
It is saying it's really
not worried about deficits.
It's willing to lend
to the US government
at all time low interest rates.
It's not expecting
any inflation.
If anything, the
bond market is saying
that the biggest
risk in the economy
is continued sluggish growth.
The biggest risk in
the economy is maybe
even some form of deflation.
So this super low bond
yields right over here
would be an argument
that well, yeah,
if you believe what the
bond market is saying,
we, one, definitely should not
suck money out of the economy.
And the risks of maintaining
high levels of debt
might not be as high as some
people are saying-- that you're
not going to see interest
rates and inflation go
through the roof tomorrow.
Now, if you ascribe to the
second point of view that,
OK, yes, we should
be responsible.
We should start to at
minimum lower our deficit,
and over time, as a percentage
of GDP, lower our debt.
The other question is,
how do you do that?
The Republicans would
want to do it mainly
through spending cuts, while the
Democrats would want to do that
possibly through spending
cuts, but also by letting some
of the tax cuts on
the wealthy expire,
and maybe even adding
some other tax.
And so these two charts inform
some of those positions.
And I'm trying to give as
balanced of an approach
as I can.
So for a Democrat,
they might look
at this chart right over here.
And they might say, well,
look, average tax rates
for the highest
income taxpayers--
if you look at a
historical basis,
it looks like it's
relatively low.
And a lot of this
comes out of the idea
that even though
the marginal tax
rates are higher than
what you see here,
high income taxpayers--
a lot of their income
might be from capital
gains, from dividends.
Those are taxed at 15%.
They also might have a more
sophisticated accountants
who can get them
more deductions.
And so that's why you
have them paying--
and they're getting more
sophisticated as time goes by.
And that's why you see
this trend going down.
And so this could be an
argument, well at least
relative to historical basis,
that this category of folks
might be able to
afford to pay more.
There's also another argument
in terms of a stimulus argument,
or how to minimize the
impact on the economy.
So if you have $1 that you
want to somehow stimulate
the economy with.
Well one, the government
could spend the money.
And there are many
arguments-- very
good arguments-- why the
government is not always
the most efficient
spender of money,
and not always spending
it in the best way.
But they will
definitely spend it.
So you give it to
the government.
You give to the
government, they'll
definitely spend
it, and then some.
So they'll definitely
spend that dollar.
At least it will enter
into the economy.
Now, if you give it
to the middle class,
they are also
likely to spend it.
Or, to spend a good chunk of
it-- maybe save a little bit.
And the argument would
be that if you give it
to someone who's affluent,
they are likely to save it.
Now, saving is not
always a bad thing.
If you are low on investment,
you need more savers.
If interest rates were
going through the roof
right over here.
That means that we don't
have enough supply of money.
In which case, it
would make sense
that we would try
to incent savers.
So if you have a situation
of-- in the late '70s,
where you have inflation
going through the roof.
You want people to
actually invest more.
You want a higher
supply of money.
Makes complete sense
to put more money
in the hands of people who
are likely to save and invest
that money.
But here, at least if you
believe the bond market,
it looks like we have
a demand problem.
That it's actually very
cheap to get capital.
If anything, there's a
surplus of capital out there.
But there's not
enough demand in order
for people to get the economy
to run at its potential.
So a Democratic
argument would be,
look, if we're going
to have this dollar,
the person that
we're best off giving
it to is the middle class.
Or possibly to some
degree, the government.
Because at least
they will spend it.
It will help stimulate
the economy here,
it will go into
savings, but that
doesn't seem like what the
government needs right now.
Now, the counter argument that
you might get from someone
at the right is that, first,
the government is just
a hugely inefficient
spender of capital.
And there's a lot of
evidence to-- you definitely
need a government, but they
don't always spend money
in the most efficient--
and even sometimes it
leads to levels of corruption.
And often times,
when you do something
in the name of stimulus,
maybe it might make sense
to do it in the short term, but
once that program is in place,
it's very hard to
remove that program.
People start to depend on it,
even when you, in theory, you
don't need the stimulus anymore.
It's a very hard to shrink
the size of government.
And there's some
argument for that.
If you look at outlays--
government expenditures
as a percentage of
GDP-- it does look
like, on a historical
basis, it is high.
Now, to some degree,
this is due to the fact
that we have entered into kind
of a major recessionary phase.
You see that in all of
the major recessions,
the government gets less revenue
and has to do more outlays.
This happens in every-- well,
I would say in most recessions.
And this happened
in dramatic form,
where we started to
have more outlays.
We had-- actually this point, we
had wars that we were funding.
And we were doing these trillion
dollar stimulus packages.
And we have these
trillion bailouts.
At the same time
that the economy
was receding right over here.
But just when you
look at this, it
does look like the
government spending,
as a percentage of GDP,
is at historical highs.
And as we say, as the
arguement would have it,
it's very hard to
get that to shrink,
even when it should
be shrinking.
And it's often being deployed
in less than efficient ways.
So I will leave you there.
My intent really is not to
sway you one way or the other.
But to really just hope that
you have good information when
you think about the issues
surrounding the fiscal cliff.